alright I'm Kristian harloff and I'm
Tiffany somebody that our guest on
today's episode is dis storm power this
is movie so our shows more than six
seconds it's not vine um I think all
right so let's do the show
okay so glad that we have you back sorry
about the mix-up no problem you got to
pay for my over how far let's talk about
your favorite film from 2015 Oh for me
probably was Jurassic world was was like
some hesitation because they had Star
Wars too and I was and when I was a kid
like mofo knowledge is like really good
for me you know it had to be a toss-up
uh-huh Jurassic world just did it for me
you know I didn't think that the
Jurassic series what I would come back
and I was like oh this is dope you have
a series yeah well you have a video that
you do every year called wrap up yeah I
do our do a wrap up and so that's and
that's where you wrap about everything
that happened throughout the year can
you tell us a little bit about that Matt
skills is a rapper from Virginia and he
started doing things like that you know
back in the day after Matt's guilty then
in 2009 I decided well I'm gonna start
doing wrap up - you don't just do
YouTube though I mean your honor could
be on but you don't just do social media
you have you're in fashion now so you
started your own line what are you doing
in as far as fashion I've partnered with
Tilly's and we started a clothing line
okay you know and I always wanted to do
clothing so what I did was that that
partner with them I came out with some
teaching and try to keep as many M&Ms an
interesting that you have so you brought
punked back yeah with King batch right
I'm be eg tell us about that we tried to
pump back a few times and it didn't work
so I said you know you how waste of my
friends Tom can you at least make him to
co-host okay he became the co-host on
pump would you call your rivalry with
that's friendly no no oh he's going he's
gone again this isn't mine Tiffani and I
have a rivalry and it's the problem you
don't know it's cool I saw the show last
week when y'all was
on the revenue always was 14 million
anyways in 60 the actual box office
total for the revenant was 39 million
what's means this week's loser should
comes from a YouTube viewer pyroblast
3000 loser should dress like kylo Ren
and do the dance hit the Quan I have no
idea what hit the Quan I don't know what
that is I have my dance instructor right
there Janina no this has to be a happy
thing hey I won we should be talking
about it how about next week's bet right
along to I'm gonna bet thirty nine point
five million tips what do you lose I'm
gonna say 41 Hey
stop dancing and having fun be miserable
like me cuz I'm the winner
no I'm just it now please good the
answer by the way all right well now
that that loser should is out of the way
what's up Michael I was actually pretty
fun so make sure you guys send in even
more using the hashtag loser should in
the comments below on Facebook and on
Twitter so that Christians got something
probably not quite as fun to do next
week oh come on you losers
hey you know what I'm gonna lay the job
Weezy was on ride-alongs too because
those my homies bonded over the dancing
the show's been going really well but
you have to lie to impress if you don't
believe me I'll ask them something right
now anything anything you want me to ask
all right why don't you ask them what
their rap duo name would be what's up
fellas man thanks for joining us here
appreciate thanks for having us thank
you for having us no problem you don't
have to be that loud we yeah you're not
that far away
okay what's cool okay look look I got a
question for you check it out since I
host don't believe that I know y'all
look check this out if y'all had a rap
duo
would the name be our name will be ice
cube
hey bodies record it's starring yours
truly ice and cube we'd have a group
name and it'll be called
soon to be solo that's a good name
what murder your partner did be a nice
rap group alright look look y'all thanks
for joining us y'all have a good one I
appreciate y'all coming through signing
out defrost the exes days storm you know
what it doesn't matter the point is are
you talking to my people pointing I made
it happen
pretty slow moving news week so let's
try and think Oh Star Wars do you guys
hear that Star Wars is now the most
profitable domestic movie of all time
and Harrison Ford is the most profitable
actor oh no what about the Golden Globes
the Martian and the revenant won Best
Picture Wars yeah anything else happen
all right game time
the game that we're playing today is
gone in six seconds
so in this popcorn container are the
titles of some thoughts some song songs
a songs in there in there in this
popcorn container are titles of songs
from big movies and what you guys have
to do is you've got 6 seconds to hum the
song and try and get me to guess it mmm
do you know okay I'm ready
oh god
throw it out that's all I got a
Christmas song or wind beneath my wings
no this is for the tie for the hole for
all the popcorn there's no more in here
thanks guys
Griffin didn't win DeStorm didn't win I
didn't win
you guys didn't win so let's just end
the show thank you so much to DeStorm
for hanging out with us on board
threesome and you guys make sure you
follow him on every form of social media
Twitter Instagram YouTube snapchat vine
vine YouTube BlackPlanet meet gente my
space my space is my favorite one and
get ready for our first ever movie
threesome on the road in a couple of
weeks but we knit up with Sundance don't
and make sure you subscribe right over
there and then look at this right here
go through every episode of movie three
something right there and then download
the Fandango and then download the movie
clips find angle app on your smart phone
and join us every week here on
you